well meanwhile Iran's supreme leader has
denied any involvement in the Hamas
attacks on Israel he told an audience at
a military academy that tan supports and
defends Palestine and its
resistance supporters of the regime and
some officials of the occupying regime
have said some nonsense comments over
the past few days they introduce Iran as
the one who is behind this operation
they made a mistake we of course defend
Palestinians we kiss the forehead and
arms of the Brave Fighters and youth of
Palestine yes it's true but those who
say that non-p Palestinians were behind
what was done they do not know
Palestinians well they have
underestimated the nation of Palestine
that is their
mistake let's speak now to dorsa Jabari
she joins us live from Iran's Capital
tan dorsa give us an idea of just how
significant it is that we've got the
supreme leader coming out himself to
deny any involvement from Iran in this
Hamas
operation well it's certainly
significant the supreme leader Ayatollah
Ali is the commanderin-chief of the
country's Armed Forces but his comments
weren't just about this specific denial
he spent about 10 minutes or so talking
about the events that have unfolded over
the past few days at the graduation
ceremony atam ali uh Military Academy
here in the capital uh he highlighted
the fact that there was uh many people
are calling what took place a failure uh
in terms of the Israeli military
intelligence uh but he said it's
irreparable what has happened meaning
that the Israelis will not be able to
fix the damage that's been done to them
he also highlighted the fact that this
was the the by the will of the
Palestinian people themselves uh who
carried out the attacks and uh he said
that uh right now what is happening is
that Israel is using the narrative that
they are the oppressed they've turned
things around the oppressors have become
the oppressed and he said they're using
that as a justification to carry out the
strikes on Gaza and he said that this
will also um see a harsh blow to them
really serving as a warning to the
Israeli officials who have been pointing
the finger at Iran and the supreme
leader himself taking the opportunity to
deliver his own warning back to them and
the supreme leader da also expressing
solidarity with the Palestinian people
just tell us give us an idea what
support Iran actually
gives well officially uh Iran has not
admitted to providing Financial or
military assistance to the resistance
groups uh in Palestine but they have
said that they do provide humanitarian
assistance uh over the years and that uh
it will continue the supreme leader
highlighting the fact that it is the
duty of all um Muslim nations to come to
the aid of the Palestinian Ians in
whatever uh shape or form they require
so he really left it very vague in terms
of how and what form the assistance
would take place but he said that it is
their duty to do so I think it would be
up to the Palestinians to decide what
they require and what they ask for uh
but I think it's certainly the
relationship Iran has had with Palestine
has always been very strong and very
close the leadership here since the
revolution of 1979 has seen it as has
seen Israel as one of their number one
enemy they don't recognize the state as
such and they believe that it is the
Palestinian people's right uh to live
freely in their own land so the
relationship has always been a very
close one and now it appears that that
will
continue okay dorsa Jabari joining us
there from tan thanks very much for
bringing us the latest then